this is a production of Cornell
University
welcome everybody where the be reward is
a wonderful award that our allows
students to work and study abroad for at
least a half year or sometimes a year
the year a half past two cities our
interests abroad and it's a great award
and so I started
we're set in mariposa counties Thank You
Nina so this is me paying up one of the
conditions of the jury reward is to give
a talk once you've been back and because
of the timing of my employment after my
Master's I kind of had a high tail it in
August when there weren't students
around so I was thankful for the
opportunity to come back here at this
time of year and talk to you all about
what I did so this will be the first of
many Lord of the Rings references so
brace yourself but this is my story of
there and back again a juror word tale
by Lindsey Jordan so I've wanted to go
to New Zealand since i virtually can
remember my father went when he was
around 15 it was with a rotary exchange
kind of program he went and stayed in
Rotorua with a new zealand family and so
I grew up hearing tales of how awesome
new zealand was and i always wanted to
go I also grew up loving penguins and
found out the home of little blue fairy
penguins or little blue penguins is New
Zealand so since I could pretty much
walk I wanted to go see penguins
similarly to say I was slightly obsessed
with Lord of the Rings when I was in
high school is an understatement I saw
each film eight times and theaters so to
say that New Zealand is the home of Lord
of the Rings I had wanted to go I
desperately wanted to go in fact when I
was around 18 19 when I graduated high
school and I thought oh instead of going
to do the European backpack thing i'll
go through New Zealand i'll drive around
and see all the sights I was dead set on
doing this and my parents sort of look
at me kind of concerned more for the
nerdiness than my safety and ultimately
though you can't rent a car until you're
25 so I was 19 and I said damn it i will
go to
zeeland when I'm 25 and drive around I
didn't realize how perfect that life
plan was going to end up I happen to get
into one of the industry's where New
Zealand is a very relevant thing the New
Zealand wine industry is quite famous
for its savvy on Blanc production
there's many other smaller regions that
are emerging for their cooler climate
style Pinot Noir and other varietals and
it's quite known in the world of wine so
I happen to be fortunate enough to have
this desire and passion to go to New
Zealand and the career to back it up so
and I had to choose a location for the g
reward I was sort of flopping and
flipping around the idea of Australia vs
new zealand I knew I'd be gone about six
months which isn't quite enough time to
do two countries justice and I just
thought this was going to be the time to
pursue my dream of going to New Zealand
so I did so this all started Cloudy Bay
is probably the most famous labels in
New Zealand they're famous for their
sabe on Blanc of the mall borough region
I remember seeing this exact label
presented on a screen much like this and
my intro to wines class at Davis and
once again had that thought of well I
should go there one day so to give you
an idea there are several wine regions
in New Zealand and you'll hear me talk
about a lot of them over the course of
my travels there's a tiny concentrated
area in the north part of the North
Island near auckland and my he ki Island
kind of premium very small production
they're the kind of other bigger more
famous regions are the Hawke's Bay
region you know the cities of Napier and
Hastings they're really developing quite
a reputation for their sera you have
Blenheim the city which is in the mall
borough region which is the bulk of
where the wine you've probably heard of
comes from it is the king of savvy on
blanc in the country you also have wines
going to the Canterbury region around
christchurch and there's also quite a
reputation for Pinot developing down
near the queenstown o tago peninsula
region so you'll hear me mention these
but the idea is to know that New Zealand
has several distinct wine-growing
regions with different varietals kind of
indifferent popularity in each I've
quite enjoyed New Zealand wines ever
since that kind of went down this path
and it was a really awesome experience
to
to explore all these regions on my own
so I kind of traveled the QE way I
booked a ticket and said I'll figure it
out one in there so I landed in Auckland
and that's where my journey kind of
started my first day I bought a car
turns out you don't actually need a
rent-a-car in New Zealand if you're
there for over a couple months there's a
very large second-hand car market from
Asia that comes in so it's actually much
more common for it through there for any
significant amount of time to just by
kind of a clunker that's what I did I
landed I probably hadn't slept in 36
hours I said let's go buy a vehicle
because that's a great idea I was taught
by a really wonderful little Maori man
how to drive on the other side of the
road to I was taken up and around
Auckland given a view of the city all
while trying to not be paralyzed in fear
of driving on the road side of the road
you'll see a recurring theme of this
presentation is penguins at all costs I
saw penguins every single time I could
so there's a Kelly Tarleton aquarium in
Auckland and I got to see some king
penguins there and I also took part of a
high tea which is very classic New
Zealand thing to do I don't know if
anybody saw Chinese presentation but
it's kind of the English influence on
New Zealand culture high tea especially
in Auckland is a quite enjoyable
experience so I've got to play the
tourist a little bit I then made my way
up to fenger a whs pronounced f as I
discovered in New Zealand up to what's
called the Northland this area is a
little more I won't call it tropical but
subtropical kind of climate quite warm
and humid this is ocean beach this is
where i spent my New Year's Eve
welcoming in 2014 a day earlier than all
of you here because of the time change
all I can say is this is one of many
many many beautiful pictures of New
Zealand and it was an awesome experience
to get to celebrate the change of the
year so I'm gonna have a question I
wrote it on the team at Davis all four
years my undergrad and where else in New
Zealand could I say that I went swimming
with a horse we went down we change the
swimsuits went down into that water the
pacific view see right there then had a
picnic lunch with Savion block out on
the Sun so I can say is I had some fun
on this trip as well and this is finger
a Falls lots and lots of waterfalls
throughout New Zealand this is kind of a
you know picturesque every tourist goes
to see whangarei falls in this region on
a horticultural note this is also the
region
I made out of hike to see the Kauri tree
carry trees don't grow incredibly tall
they don't have any branches kind of
below anywhere below the very crown of
the tree they grow to be incredibly old
these old growth trees are kind of a
sight to behold and their height and
their age and they're very well
protected in New Zealand and because
they have a very shallow routing system
they actually often build a little
boardwalk planks to go around the tree
so you can go up to them without
damaging the fragile root system below
so I was fortunate enough to go out on a
few hikes kind of out in the middle of
nowhere you in New Zealand it's very
frequent to have trails go through
farmland so you kind of look your
tromping in the middle of a you know
sheep pen and you're looking for the
next trail marker so I followed a couple
of those to go see kauri trees
additionally I stopped at my very first
winery the Northland while not a super
famous region for wine these days is one
of the very first regions planted in New
Zealand probably due to its proximity to
Auckland and early English settlement
but Longview wines was kind of fun at
the tasting room there i found out of
the winemaker son had actually gone to
East the eastern institute of technology
or EIT who I was going to be helping out
on a research project with so realizing
the kind of influence of EIT graduates
throughout the country was kind of fun
very early on that's a very nice
Chardonnay that I enjoyed so Carrie
Carrie is where I swim with the horses a
little more north of finger a made my
way back down to the kind of the first
true wine region I visited in New
Zealand which is why he Key Island this
is sort of a destination get away from
Auckland tourist spot these days very
desirable white sand beaches but also
has quite a large but a cultural
presence you take a little ferry over
from Auckland get a great view of the
city on your way out and this vineyard
in particular I'd like to make note of
it's called Jurassic Ridge this guy has
a degree in geology he hires a few
viticultural consultants as well his
wines are spot-on he did a really
amazing multiplet giano and some of
those other Italian warmer climate Reds
this island gets a lot warmer but has
some wint has a lot of wind coming off
of the ocean and has humidity issues so
it was kind of a very interesting
climate to be growing some grapes but
they were pretty there are some pretty
spectacular wines but that being said
it's a huge tourist destination this is
the view from cable bay vineyards which
is famous for having a nice little
luncheon I did partake in
and we had like I said big white sand
beaches the coolest part about the way i
did this is there was a pass you got
with the ferry which is you paid you
hopped on the ferry and there was a
little vineyard bus that took you on a
little loop of all the different
wineries and I did the math and I could
have hit about five so I hit all five
that I could but there's actually plenty
more than that but it's you know it's a
day it's a day trip it's an overnight
trip for a lot of Aucklanders and
there's sort of this tourism that drives
I think the local wine of commercial
industry and it was a beautiful location
is all I can say and some very
interesting wines run there so after
making my way back down from Waikiki
Island I made a stop in Hobbiton before
heading down to the center so hobbiton
this was this was going to happen it's
actually happen twice so and I realized
that basically her Fred students are
hobbits we grow things and we like
drinking beer so honestly it was like
Rica muting with my people what's cool
about hobbiton that I should note is
they actually have full year round
gardeners and they actually garden the
location the little farm lands they have
in plots to be in season with you know
with the climate and that's a compost
pile right there so they actually do
sort of make an effort to maintain it
looking like it was an actual little
agricultural farming community among
hobbits paid gardeners from the facility
so it's a paid tour the site is actually
owned by a sheep farmer there they have
quite a large number a head of sheep in
its a sheets are all surrounding sheep
farm and then New Line Cinema agreed to
leave the Hobbit holes behind when they
left when they made more of the Rings
they actually stripped out most of them
you could kind of see like circles of
hobbit hole doors in the in the dirt but
it was nothing like this but when they
did the hobbit they rebuilt it up and
the owners of the farm said please leave
everything because they were already
running tours but this was actually like
a thousand times better than just having
some plywood doors so it's everything
and like I said that's bag n from the
movie if any of you recognize and it's
fantastic I also want to make a note in
the lower corner there that's a chicory
plant chicory was one of my undermined
cover crops I grew here and I such
Hickory everywhere in New Zealand so I
don't know sort of like your work
follows you no matter where you go but
so I thought that was sort of an
interesting note has beautiful purple
flowers so so I then have made my way
down to the center of the country where
I'm traveling alone and I'm not a
particularly avid hiker but I said damn
it I'm going to climb Mount Doom this is
matt mauro hawaii it's part of the
tongue guerrero state park there's a
really really famous day hike it's about
10 hour day hike called the trigger euro
alpine crossing this is a sub route you
can decide to take off and that's where
all I really cared about doing so most
people have a bus drop them off at the
beginning of the day they hike this
whole crossing I get picked up the end I
said nope i'm going to hike up in roa
your mount doom and hike back so they
describe the chunga rio crossing as
difficult very difficult and i will say
there's a lot of hiking and stairs and
mountain climbing you climb up you know
some good elevation and you got some
good miles under you they describe the
sub trail climbing up nara hoey is also
difficult that's like comparing
community college art class to cornell
engineering there are different levels
of difficult so I that is a picture I
would have turned to my left to take
when I was climbing or rock climbing my
arms hurt the next day I also be in the
worrywart I am packed my bag with like
the 20 pounds of like extra rain gear
and water and snacks just in case all
the stuff happens if they warn you about
so I'm alone climbing up a four hour
hike in that but I did it I did it and I
wasn't probably never prouder of myself
I didn't have a ring to throw in it but
at that point I called it a day and then
of course so that's the descent it's
more like skiing than it is um hiking
but I can say I did it it was one of
those like I had to do before I die
things and I can say I did it so that's
an arrow hwy up says three hours that's
probably true if you were unfit and
carrying 20 pounds of gear but there is
no actual trail you just kind of can see
those white lines or sort of the rough
guide lines that you make to make your
way up there but I had to do it and I'm
very glad to say i did it and i never
need to do it again so from so you can
see tongariro national park is the
southern region below the lake and then
there's lake taupo that large like right
in the center of the north island and
tap over the cute little town and then
from there kind of
Mountains over to the Hawke's Bay region
to Napier and the kind of more in a
culturally important town of Hastings I
was very very fortunate to have a
connection from my Davis days dr. mark
krasnow worked in the lab of Mark
Matthews when I was undergrad doing
undergraduate research there and I have
a glee knew he was in New Zealand and I
sort of reached out to him around the
time of the jury reward that I heard and
I said hey I'm going to be a new zealand
I'd love to help out with something I
don't know what you're doing I don't
know you know currently research I know
you were doing some cost resetting
research love to hear from you since hey
Lindsay actually stopped the cluster
thinning research what we're doing a lot
of work on right now is under vine
management treatments for sustainable
practices which is basically the basis
of what my thesis was here at Cornell so
I was like well that was convenient so I
agreed to help out on the project that
had there's two sites of this project
one in the Hawke's Bay and one in the
mall borough region I was going to be
helping out at the sister site in
Marlborough that's where i was going to
be based but I obviously stopped up at
Hawke's Bay marc krauss no has since
left and he's now teaching actually a
kind of wine and integrated viticulture
course for the culinary institute down
in New Jersey but his successor dr coeur
MO you can see her she's the one in the
blue shirt she's taken over the project
and she was very amazingly welcoming and
on the project you can see one of her
students Ashley there they were working
on a slightly different project but I
went out in the field with them for a
couple days and help take data it's a
really cool piece of data that they're
doing in that upper right hand corner
right there it's as opposed to doing the
rather time-consuming epq a that just
means a very big fan of and that i know
i've taken a ton of this is others
researchers in spain that have developed
a rough software program that basically
if you put a whiteboard with good enough
light so there's not too many shadows
that's always the trick is catching the
right light clouds or your friend for
this piece of data we put a whiteboard
up and put this frame they have a
program that will roughly count the
number of green pixels to white pixels
and four in New Zealand especially
looking at the number of percent gaps in
a canopy caused by a treatment it's
important you're looking to see is
something super super d vigor
getting these vines or these vines
taking a punch by having vegetation
underneath or actually in the projects I
was helping out with in Hawke's Bay for
a couple days it was in a very
interesting project because water is
included in your taxes in New Zealand
growers have the luxury of being able to
basically water when and what they want
so there hasn't been a whole lot of
actual water stress measurements and
correlations to their soil moisture
meters like saying California where
water is very restrictive we know a lot
more on that end so one of these
projects was literally looking at
commercial vineyard sites that had soil
moisture probes and correlating them to
the pre-dawn and midday stand water
potentials of the vine so that these
growers have a better tool of
understanding what these soil moisture
readings are actually relating to win
their vine before it sort of was like oh
it reached this level sure I should
probably irrigate so that was one of the
projects and like I said we went around
to multiple commercial vineyards where
this project was going on that bottom
right-hand corner that's actually the
student vineyard on the EIT campus and I
want to make note it's actually just
been mowed but at the bottom and that
inner Oh cover crop is actually chicory
so there is a student a former student
named Steve wheeler who'd hit his
master's looking at using trickery and
in two rows of vineyards I've must have
referenced his paper I don't even know
how many times in my own work looking at
chicory in under vine rose and I was
actually fortunate enough to meet him
the people at EIT connected me with him
and I got to meet him and talk with him
about his work and what he's doing now
so that was a very kind of fun academia
circle moment to close the gap to meet
the man whose paper I referenced at
least a dozen times and as you can see
chicory actually is used not it wasn't
you know everywhere but I certainly did
see it being intentionally used as an
interim cover crop in New Zealand so
this was the site the sister site of
website I would be working on the
project basically there were three
different under vine treatments that's
me out at elephant hill there were
actually two sites at to commercial
vineyards in both merlot and Syrah and
the Hawke's Bay which are kind of the
important varietals for those regions
and you can see here there's this
awesome signage that would explain when
treatments start and stopped because
New Zealand it's very very common to
hire individual contractors to do most
of your vineyard maintenance so I'm in
this right I'll hire my spray contractor
oh I need cultivation under the vine or
herbicide application all higher that
contractor so it's a lot of this sort of
piecemeal labor work so anyways they
were hiring contractors to do their
maintenance under vines so there's sort
of very nice labeling out in the field
and it's actually the elephant Hill
sites are really famous and beautiful
winery in the Hawke's Bay region so it's
kind of fun to get to see a research
project out there and just to note you
can see the sign on the right here
that's this little logo about New
Zealand sustainable wine-growing to
enter any wine competition in New
Zealand you must have the certification
so there's a lot of push to maintain
these sort of internal sustainability
standards and meet this labeling kind of
regulation if you want to call it
because it lets you enter wine
competitions so I thought that was a
really cool movement to see within New
Zealand and see it widespread in New
Zealand since I think sustainable
labeling shifting to meeting the needs
for a specific region and climate is a
really important thing in Middle culture
so I thought that was a cool thing to
see and I've note all the shooting signs
birds are a huge problem in New Zealand
birds are huge problem in New Zealand
the only place I've seen a Morse as long
island actually but um so they literally
put someone with blanks and a you know
normally a pump action on the back of an
8th ed or truck and drive around
different blocks shooting because it's
one of the best bird scare tactics they
have so when they actually say shooting
they're not just talking bird cannons
they actually means someone in the back
of a truck shooting a shotgun so that's
that's always sort of fun they would use
real shells they said and take the birds
up but they're worried about the lead
content in the vineyard so because it's
birds are a huge problem in fact you can
see I'm there early enough in the season
that these aren't netted yet as soon as
we're raisin so when the berries start
to soften and accumulate sugar and turn
color in the case of the red varieties
through the hip arrays and those Nets
have to go up because otherwise that's
going to just be a nice little lunch for
a bird so these are the women who
wonderfully hosted me and showed me
around while I was a TI t that's moving
from left to right that's ting ting
that's dr coeur MO ashley her student
myself and dr. patrick king i felt very
very fortunate to have these amazing
women show me around and this was sort
of an amazing round table dinner on my
last night in town where we realized it
was you know five women of viticulture
all at one table all from around the
world which was sort of interesting and
awesome and so I'm very very grateful
for the opportunity experience they gave
me and how much I was able to learn
about the region and New Zealand wine
growing from them as well as welcome
they welcomed me on helping them out on
a project so I'm very very thankful and
we'll take that moment to give a shout
out to that so I also apparently got
into the mountain climbing mobiles in
New Zealand which is so funny if you
know me but I decided to climb came out
of pique que mata peak is this sort of
mountain in the middle of the Hawke's
Bay region and that's me having ascended
the peak petrohue I was staying with had
some friends who kind of do this walk
every more in every Sunday morning I
said sure I'll come walk up a mountain
hill I can do that well I ended up
breaking off with one of the men of the
group who I didn't know it but was had
formerly been like a professional like
race Walker and so took me up these
switchback hills where I thought I was
going to die but I did it and he
wonderfully took the photo for me and
you can see sort of the beauty of this
vineyard an agricultural there's a lot
of apple production in this region to a
lot of stone fruits but that's the hawks
bay and the river and it's just it's a
stunning region but i highly recommend
going i had some fantastic surahs' i
highly recommend the bullnose sera which
also happened to be one of the research
sites for us so making my way from south
finally I did a little detour into
Martin borough they're a little tiny bit
of cultural area outside of Wellington
that capital Martin borough was actually
having it's like summer riesling event
so sort of funny that I traveled halfway
around the world to have a summer
Riesling but very small production very
boutique guys but some really cool
things going on there some completely
organic growers they're kind of doing
figuring their style out but it was a
fun little stop on the way and then
Wellington is quite famous for it has
this massive garden that you actually
take a cable car up to this very steep
hill fact if you go to the University
there you take this cable car basically
to get to campus every day which is pic
is kind of awesome and I happen to see
the hydrangeas in like full bloom I
happen to hit I was walking through and
happened to hit an outdoor music
concerts that they apparently do in the
summer all day or every every weekend
for most the afternoon
in the in the beautiful botanical garden
so I said sure I'll sit down for a free
outdoor concert so that was my little
experience in Wellington that was really
kind of awesome and amazing to see such
an amazing public garden there so to get
now sort of my North Island experience
time to head on south so you take the
ferry to get from the north of South
Island and it's actually kind of a
beautiful ride if you hit it during the
day because you go through the mall
borough sounds which is this sort of I
you can see this like Peninsula I you
Lindy part of the north part of the
South Island absolutely stunning ride in
and just to make a note pretty much
anything you're getting in New Zealand
because it will have been brought in to
Auckland if it's in the South Island
it's come on one of these fairies so all
the one that's made the South Island all
the mall borough South blanc is being
put onto trucks normally not in a bottle
form normally in a tanker form being
tankard across the ferry then driven up
to Auckland where it's been bottled all
your food all your products so it sort
of puts in perspective the enormous cost
of living in New Zealand but it was sort
of interesting to see that half the time
on the ferry you're more battling cargo
space and cargo room with trucks as well
as just passengers like myself well the
kid this is one of the apparently one of
the roughest patches of see the fairies
cross they will cancel the berries if it
gets too bad they only have a slow ferry
now they don't have a fast ferry anymore
in part because of the potentially rocky
waters I took it twice both times for
pretty smooth sailing but that is I
certainly have heard not always the case
so I did a quick detour so if you look
on the part of the South Island if you
kind of there's the city of Nelson you
went more West than that you'd see what
is abel tasman park I was told I when I
asking everyone I know who had been in
New Zealand what do I need to do
everyone says hands down abel tasman
book like first breath and then oh yeah
you can do these other things but
everyone says abel tasman park and i
will give everyone this from the same
advice if you go to New Zealand do
anything but go to April tasman park
probably the most stunning thing you'll
see in your life you can do a whole hike
along the whole coast it takes four or
five days I did not do that because I
did not have the equipment or the time
because I was sort of sneaking this in
before i started my job but I did do a
little a couple day trips where they
have little boats go down to the various
little landings it's uninhabited this is
like a state park but it's quite
frequented by these boats and very
that take people there every day the
picture of that rock it's split apple
rock there's a big Maori mariya the
traditional people are the native
peoples of New Zealand there's a lot of
Maori legend about the acts of the Maori
warrior that carved that rock into but
you can kayak around that if you want I
mostly just hung out in the beach and
hiked and it's stunning Beach and forest
so all I can say is go to New Zealand go
to abel tasman so finally made it down
to mull borough the wine region that I
was going to be calling home for the
majority of my trip anyway most people
heard if you've heard of a wine from New
Zealand's I can almost guarantee its can
be a mole burrows to style South Blanc
in fact saying I should send to smoke
there i should say it's a mole grossed
out books marlborough sauvignon blanc
but moral style south blanc is now a
recognised style and New Zealand this
often means more green and herbaceous
you get fresh cut grass bell pepper but
also a lot of fruit I get a lot of
passion fruit off of a lot of the more
better than muldrow South blancs a lot
of bright citrus so it's as big
in-your-face grassy green fruity wine
decent levels of acid this is a cooler
ish climate it's a growing region you
can see here there's a lot of growers a
lot of growers that aren't attached to
wineries and this is an interesting
dynamic that i'll try to explain there's
a lot of contract wineries meaning your
big winery and your your space your
tanks and your labors sort of up for bid
by someone who wants to pay you to like
they contract out their wine here's my
fruit make wine out of it and in fact
the vast majority of labels you're going
to see in the market don't have a
tasting room winery available in fact
there's very little class over of those
kind of wineries because New Zealand is
largely an export market most of their
wine is being taken out of their country
and it's meant for our shelves isn't you
know united state heavy export to United
States Sweden Canada Europe and so
that's who they're marketing to and if
you're exporting your wine anyway might
as well pay some of those the facilities
to make your label and get it out of
there so there's lots of this still
contract growers so I'm a wine grape
grower and i sell my grapes to someone
looking to buy wines there's still a lot
of that going on some lots of growers
168 wineries in the region with over
six thousand acres sabi on Blanc is king
you can see it's over eighty five
percent of what's planted their lobby on
Blanc is where the demand is and what
the region is known for that being said
I think Pinot Noir grows very well there
and I think Pinot is starting to develop
quite the reputation in New Zealand it's
just my two cents but if you wanted to
you know get in early you'd see the
other varietals on there that make a bit
of an appearance chardonnay pinot gris
riesling there's a smattering of other
varieties at is VY help from one of the
wineries there for example so you see
the kind of a funny mix of stuff going
on but salve or as they call it savvy is
king and you can see per diem is the
bulk of the acreage there so this is
sort of a little cutesy map you can get
but I definitely lived on a little bit
so the town of Blenheim kind of right
around here which is where I lived and
kind of where the actual city part is
and then you have this valley encompass
by two mountain ranges and this is the
mall Roe Valley and what's interesting
is they sort of sub divide it into three
little regions all of these are pretty
cool regions these are not reaching the
hot temperatures of Australia or
anything like that I'd say they're
warmer than maybe our summers here but
we're looking at what is considered a
cool climate viticulture it's one of the
reasons I was attracted of going to New
Zealand as well after having gotten
great experience in both California and
New York I was kind of looking for
someone a little bit more in between
someone a little bit different for
pulling upon some of the cool climate
experience in New York I was able to
understand the situation in New Zealand
a lot better that being said all of
these are dry compared to say the
Northeast they do get in season rainfall
however so this is these guys are going
to be wetter than California or
something like that but we're looking at
a comparatively dry climate to say like
the Northeast that being said I happen
to be there during one of the wettest
falls on record so I guess I brought it
with me so to give you a bit of
background at least in the Northeast
you're getting bud break around May in
California it's normally the first week
in april and then you kind of go through
brazen that ripening is happening August
or so harvesting september-october and
those leaves are going dormant or those
mines are going dormant you're dropping
leaves in November everything switched a
little bit in the southern hemisphere so
that
stuffs starting to happen more like
September I arrived remember in December
January's that's when I was popping
around helping out with that EIT
research so those berries we're just
starting to go through brazen a little
bit after I got there those don't quite
line up there was more like februari
January that brazen was occurring and
then harvest is starting depending on
the varietal late februari in an earlier
mid-february but most likely early March
and then you're normally got everything
off the vine by May so there's sort of a
little cycle there that was kind of fun
to see and very disorienting when you
have three summers in a row so a very
interesting and cool Institute that New
Zealand has is plant food research they
have facilities up in Auckland but they
also have Amma blenheim station which
predominantly and makes sense focuses a
lot on grape and wine research they have
a little a research winery which they
did a lot of little micro fermentation
so that was really cool to see that
technology there's some cool stuff going
on I helped out with research for a
couple days to sort of see what was on
dr. demian Martin showed me around he
sort of the director there and it was
awesome to meet him and have him
introduced me to all the research
scientists there and he's the one
connected me to helping out and kind of
you know following everyone around for
the day in that upper right hand corner
you can see that kind of computer and
that looks like a psycho I don't even
know she'll scanning thing it's the best
student best piece of technology I've
ever seen you throw berries at the
bottom and it counts the berries and
gives you size of berries so no more
hand counting berries so that was really
cool for comparing treatments to see if
it hadn't effect on Barry sizing at the
bottom left hand corner there was a
research scientist their DN mundi he's
awesome guy he was looking at a lot of
potential kind of paints as we call them
for treating wood against fungal
infections in the wind dormant season
prunings and so these are all has grown
up little samples to see which funguses
were growing within the presence of
these different applications and then
that's the lab of dr. Mike trot that I
was helping doing that very sorting with
he was really awesome he showed me
around kind of took me under his wing
and I'm really really thankful for all
of that he even invited me to a
traditional keva barbecue where I met
dr.
smart so I was really kind of fun but um
he showed me a couple of his trials
going on that potted one had to do with
nitrogen fertilization and the name is
doing another project that related leaf
removal and hurdling different shoots
and seeing nutrient transport
differences then he showed me a couple
of the research vineyards that they were
using so I was really really thankful to
get an idea of the research going on in
New Zealand in Marlborough you know
prime wine country with a plant food so
it's very thankful for that so the trial
that I was actually you know going there
to be a part of um so like I said that
we were the sister site to these trials
that were occurring in the Hawke's Bay
and we were looking at three different
treatments we were looking at mowing
under the vine so leaving whatever
plants wanted to grow there naturally
and just mowing them with a commercial
mower we looked at cultivating
underneath the vines the traditional
organic method of weed control and a
vineyard underneath the vines and we
looked at herbicide use and they were
the exact same experimental designs as
in Hawke's Bay but we looked at sabi on
Blanc these kind of this projects are
kind in the middle of this bigger block
highlighted in green and in Pinot Noir
which are the two you know those are the
top varietals and for the mall borough
region so we thought we'd look at them
for that so we took a lot of data I
helped out with at least some of it my
friend Chris Williams was sort of the
I'm gonna call him undergraduate
although he's older than me helping out
on the project and then I came along and
kind of helped him out too we did a lot
of leaf area so what you do is you pick
and sort out all those leaves cut off
the petioles and then feed them through
the scanner which gives you the leaf
areas and that ended up being a very
interesting piece of data looking at how
those were affected by those under find
treatments we took timeline photos the
vineyard to look at the establishment
and weed growth of you know the regrowth
back after you've cultivated something
or after you to apply to herbicide we
did typical petiole nutrient analysis
see how that's affecting we do those
canopy photos that I had talked about
earlier we looked at percent shaded area
underneath the vine it's kind of another
correlation to canopy sighs you know if
you have lots of big canopy you're
creating more shade on the ground then
we did normal maturity sampling lots of
maturity sampling every week just about
every other week we were sampling from
each on experimental unit 100 berries
and looking at all the traditional sugar
and acid levels looking at nutrient
level used to swimmable my
Georgian we also collected samples at
both for raised in that ripening period
and at harvest time for we used a gross
gas chromatography to look at methoxy
pyrazine and thus a vm blanc and we did
phenolic analysis on the Pinot to help
see if this chemistry is being affected
by these this is the most magic machine
that I grew to use a lot in New
Zealand's called the wine scan basically
it will do all those hard work of
measuring those bricks ta pH all those
red roads you put a little cup sample
this big in it press button she said all
the data it is a chordal of measure so
what you do is you have to calibrate it
and calibrating is a big thing with
these guys Foss makes them they aren't
cheap pieces of equipment a new one that
will also do sulfur's runs 200 plus
thousand dollars that is but if for
large-scale production wineries and for
research purposes I cannot stress how
awesome they were plant food has one and
a lot of them and some of the bigger
wineries in New Zealand have them
they're amazing for being able to
process that much data and be able to
look at it in real time and that was a
really awesome experience you can see
there that's a little that's a sight
from the Pinot research site down there
the Pinot's being naturally less
vigorous the Saudi amok there are some
fun comparisons there a lot of that data
is well as probably the process now but
I haven't looked at and gotten up to
date on all of it but it's been
interesting I was on the what was it the
second year of the trial it's going on
for a third and there's a lot of
interesting data it's sort of similar to
mine and it's looking at there might be
some nutrient effects you're looking at
lower nitrogen levels when you have
stuff growing underneath the vine
compared to when you don't have stuff
growing beneath divine and maybe some
deviation that's coming from that it'll
be interesting to see the conclusions of
the use of this site after three years
so she's given the parallels to my own
work so it's kind of fun to go see a
different way of doing kind of the same
idea and get some new ideas and
perspective on the research that's been
near and dear to me here at Cornell we
are very concerned about
yeah the D bigger problem wasn't even so
much what they're looking at it's more
the sustainable slant they're more
worried about they don't want to really
be bigger the growers are very very
nervous about that idea but the idea of
being able to say you don't use
herbicide or don't have to cultivate is
really desirable there because of this
there that sustainable kind of focused
at sustainable wine growing focus so
that's more where the drive of this
project comes from for Pinot that might
be a different story and also I happen
to be there during a year of record
yields like a dr. mark trot has a model
that predicts yields around me some alaz
work and his model predicted something
like eighty percent above normal and
everyone's like that can't be right but
it was so given the incredible high
yield of this year it wasn't such a big
deal but yeah in future years that would
be a problem most of these growers are
not looking to reduce you of whatsoever
but they really do want to eliminate
herbicide or cultivation for one those
are caught like mowing is easy mowings
cheap and easy and for them that would
be a huge advantage compared of having
to hire a contractor to come out and
cultivate or apply herbicide so that's
more this plant that they're going for
and they're wondering can they get away
with it without seeing huge
depreciations to yields or affecting
line chemistry I have never heard anyone
express it in that description I don't
actually think they're necessarily
talking about it in those terms is the
best way I can say it if anything it's
more they don't like percent gaps in the
canopy because that's considered wasted
space that could have been fruit so most
of the savvy on Blanc is being grown
like three canes in a two-tiered system
so most of its already plenty shaded
it's more that they don't want that
reduction in yield if that's a gap in
the canopy them that that could have
been a shoot that could have been a
cluster that could have been fruit that
was sold and I think especially when you
have a grower contract based industry
you saw the number of growers to
wineries like these growers are making
their money by having some decent yields
so there's that kind of counterpoint to
so sort of different very different
perspective than my research or it's
like please can we do anything to slow
these lines down that being said for
them to you know it does have seasonal
rainfall but nothing like where we are
so they're able to irrigate to control
and they will up the irrigation as they
feel nervous to get more growth and get
plenty
methoxy pyrogens and shading so at least
from what I can see the the Marlborough
style is terroir but also terroir the
sense of that water is included in your
taxes and you can irrigate so I think
that's not necessarily their huge
concern I at least that's what I gleamed
from my perspective of it so it's
definitely more of a yield loss
potential income concern that they have
been maintaining a wine style I think
the wine style is going to be there even
if you did have some reduction in yields
so the research side I was just
describing was in fact owned by so
Pernod Ricard I'll probably use these
interchangeably Pernod Ricard is the
giant corporation that owns this label
called brancott estate so it was a
winery in Marlborough called Montana for
a really long time but when / no bought
them and they wanted to start exporting
their wine you can't export a wine
called Montana from New Zealand it was
just a family name so they really abled
it as brancott so when you're there
you'll still have people call it Montana
if people call brancott people call it /
no so because Pernod as a whole the
winery / no wine makers of in marlboro
make about 16 labels but so this
research side i saw was at the renwick
estate for brink or you know under this
brancott label and they have a gorgeous
tasting room that I enjoy frequenting
and enjoying some sauce blanc and also
just sort of a sign of the
sustainability and they have this I rat
reintroducing the native Raptor bird of
New Zealand into the vineyard sites to
help control with bird damage because
like I said birds are huge pests these
guys hunt and eat them so brancott
estate is the winery and vineyards that
were helping to promote this so every
now and then you see these little
adorable hawk started out or falcons i
should say it's a new zealand falcon
tried it out and they explain what
they're doing to promote a natural bird
control and also help to reintroduce a
native species and get there get their
numbers back up so brancott estate some
people might call this factory
winemaking I just call it large-scale
winemaking we it's about more icon else
solid said's more than four million
cases of wine are produced every year at
this facility the pronoun Ricard wine
winery in Blenheim
otherwise known as brain cloud estate so
for 500 tanks i think when i was there
was well over six hundred tanks active
we used for fermentation this is under
16 different brands the one in the back
of the room that I please encourage
everyone to help yourself to a splash of
this brand caught a state that's kind of
the number one label tier that you're
going to see around other labels that
make include stoneleigh and that's
actually exported a lot to Canada so
I've actually seen it more around here
in New York and I've seen it like in
California other places but those are
there two big brands that they're quite
famous for but they do make several
others and we did take on some contract
by making as well so big mix of labels
varieties kind of fun way to get my
hands dirty and New Zealand wine making
so I after kind of helping up and
finishing a lot of the de cultural data
that needed to be collected in the field
for the research I kind of I took on a
position as a harvest lab tech at pernod
ricard refresh my wine making skills a
little bit so day my normal life as you
wake up at the crack of dawn beautiful
views you wake up at the crack of dawn
to collect permanent samples all the
winemakers met I worked on the white
wine shift the morning shift all the
winemakers wanted their wines by eight
o'clock sub that's we were out there
nice and bright and early all the
different colors and tape for different
varieties green is sev a blue is Pinot
Gris you know Chardonnay see there and
this is for the winemakers to taste and
we monitor the fermentation to see as
sugars converted to alcohol where it is
in that process make sure that the
temperature is okay for that level for
incoming juice samples say something
just got trucked into a tank will run
the juice on that wine scan that I told
you that's so wonderful and will also
run finished wines on that wine scan
that was at the end of season we're also
running a lot of analysis on juice like
for pectin and for clarity see there's
any additional processing that needed to
happen to this juice before it could be
made into the Furman sent along its way
into fermentation all of our numbers on
the juice and potential grape samples
that came in every day that we're
running on that wine scan were helped
use to make this incredibly complicated
planning board imagine a whole
conference room like this with white
boards on every side every white board
looks something like this in the thick
of harvest so every individual tag there
represents a block of grapes what's
really cool on the senior lab technician
i worked with Arvid actually came up
with this originally every day in the
lab
you get your grape sample updates or
your juice updates and you'd have to
write it a hand on a tag and these
little magnets were used around a
schedule harvesting there's those tags
though that in supermarkets that can put
that our electronic that allow them to
update prices whenever they want he
created a computer system and use these
tags to basically update the bricks ta
ph values in addition to knowing how the
cluster weights they could estimate the
tonnage and thereby estimate tractor
time down a row and how much time it
would take for an individual tractor to
harvest the block then the winemakers
can go into those big planning room and
figure out what they're bringing in each
day and the timing of it so it's this
very big complicated organization system
but it was really kind of awesome to see
and be a part of on how do you make more
than 4 million cases of wine and a
harvest a lot of planning and you hope
things don't go wrong and you hope the
weather stays nice one of my other jobs
was good thing I'm not scared of heights
I you would clamor to the top of perhaps
me for 25 story called tanks some of our
larger tanks held over five hundred
thousand litres and I would take top of
tank temperatures while we had a system
that would regulate the temperature you
had a double check because we have such
tall tanks you can get stratification so
this was double checking that this lot
of ferment was uniform so I'd scamp
around to the top of all the little cat
box papam lids drop in temperature probe
that was one of my big jobs also being
the lonely minion on the level when we
got a rainstorm where it was raining
inches an hour with probably a 50 mile
an hour plus wins I was the one you got
to go to the top of Tanks also senior
check did come with me on that one
because I think they're afraid of the
liability of me being blown over the
catwalk railings but I got to go get
completely drenched taking top of tank
temperatures for wine makers so it's it
was you know poor lowly lab tech but I
had a lot of fun doing this I got to be
active every day walking around the
winery and I you know I dividual II
touched and handle every single permit
that was going on you kind of develop
your favorite lots and you know your
problem lots it's a really fun thing to
do this is a rough view of the lab see
our vision that or hive is the big thing
by the way in New Zealand's you always
wear high vis whenever in a winery or a
vineyard very sexy and neon so you can
see arvid's on the left there and my
coworker Lydia was on the right on that
upper picture that's the lab where Lydia
is we entered in all the data we would
receive off of the wine scanner all that
analysis we did
into this giant kind of electronic lab
notebook that the wine makers could then
access and automatically right up work
orders from it's actually one of a
really cool integrated computer systems
I've seen and then the bottom picture
that's Joe she's monitoring ferments
that would have come in later that day
it's a nice big lab space but you need
it for and every inch of that lab was
used but you need it for that big of
production one of my special projects I
got to be a part of was we bought a new
line scan and this wine scandal is extra
special because it would also do sulfur
analysis for us sulfur is really
important in winemaking it guarantees
microbial stability and keeping wines
from oxidizing so when otherwise your
methods include either manual sulfur's a
picture of that large chemical looking
contraption at the top via aeration
oxidation or we actually had a machine
at the lab called a fee estar which is
very temperamental at best so being able
to eliminate the fetus star was a big
goal so the promise as I said all the
wineskins stuff is calibration based you
run manual numbers and program it and it
creates a calibration curve so as you
need very precise calibration to get
good numbers that you trust so me being
the intern who had extra time ran
hundreds maybe a thousand vandal
sulfur's on different juices and wine
testing different levels to create the
calibration curves that was sort of my
little extra contribution by the end of
season it was calibrated we were using
it for sulfur's so that was a really
nice moment also me being not there so
the normal temporary harvest lab tech
that they were used to have pestered the
lab manager and senior lab tech to teach
me capillary electrophoresis that's on
the left we use that for measuring malic
acid for standardizing that new mine
scan and I also was got to play around
with the GCMs a little bit which we use
for detecting off a room is caused by
Brittana my sees a spoiler organism and
wine so they have a bit of a program to
test through to make sure no the lots
come in too high for the Brett spoilage
and then what do you do at the end of
day of lab tech you have beer with your
friends watching rugby at a bar called
Fairweather's that was awesome that's
Chris kind of heard the left there
awesome wonderful guy his family totally
adopted me and I had Kiwi dinners on
Sunday so all I can say is a great
thanks to Chris and for his help in both
the research but also was becoming a
really good friend of mine so upon
reflection if I had to pick one thing
I've now learned from working in living
and to cool climate
cultural regions how would I define a
cool climate it's sugar try to pick one
thing it's the necessary need to add
sugar at any point in your fermentation
in a warm climate sugars kind of the
enemy you're you're waiting to keep
things on the vine to accumulate other
flavor in a room of compounds but sugar
just keeps rising you're battling the
sugar and a cool climate you often can
achieve the aromatics you want or for
other reasons or having to harvest but
you don't have the sugar you want like I
said I brought apparently the cool
coolest wettest fall they've had in a
very long time with me so I got to see
I'm sure they're embarrassed Pernod
would not be too happy for me showing
these photos but a tons literal tons and
tons and tons of sugar had to be added
especially for the later lot that were
coming in when the weather kept getting
increasingly bad so that was sort of my
mental reflection of the difference of
anyone asked me between cool climate
more climate if you ever added add sugar
your cool climate so a little bit of
moment the winemaker Greg actually led
us me and a couple other seasonal
workers and other employees through a
big tasting of all the different labels
and wines and compared this year's wines
to last year you know to pre bottled
wines it's a really fun tasting
experience to kind of get my head around
the giant portfolio of wines that I just
helped make and the line that you see
here in the screw cap bottler it's a
little special my very first week of
work I was monitoring the fermentation
of this is our low alcohol label called
her flight series line called lunch
wines that's their low alcohol Pinot
Gris in my very last week of work i
bottled out the samples to be sent to
Auckland so they could prep to bottle it
was going to be shipped out that week so
I saw whole wines from start to finish
in my little duration in New Zealand so
that was kind of a fun thing so wrapped
up harvest there had a great time and
traveled a bit my wonderful boyfriend
Dan joined me for the last part of New
Zealand and I'll show you the kind of
last bits of my travels I actually did
give this seminar I gave a seminar plant
food and I gave us an art Lincoln I'm
earlier before harvest it started but i
also got to visit christchurch again
later so blend creasy of you know dr.
creasy son who had been part of this
department is a viticulture professor at
lincoln and he and his family
wonderfully welcomed me into his home
and hosted me
and encouraged me to get a seminar there
on my work that I've done here at
Cornell that was a really wonderful
opportunity to visit the campus see
their viticulture department and their
school vineyards there and meet Glen and
kind of see the new zealand academic
side of things and like i said i would
felt very thankful to be asked to give a
seminar while i was there and like i
said i got to do a fun little visit
through Christ Church on my way I
finally got to take a little blue
penguin selfie my five-year-old self
could not have been happier though this
moment there's an Antarctic center in
christchurch where i got to go see
little blue penguins that have otherwise
been injured or incapable of being
rereleased so i was a fun way of seeing
them up close but penguins as i said are
a strong holding theme of this trip so
going down south this is big penguin
country so i stopped at 0 murru where
there's a little blue penguin colony and
you can see them at the right times of
year and i got to see them twice come up
short Colonel and they come in from the
ocean at night and you can see they have
their own little Hobbit holes that they
live in during the day and neston and
you get to see this whole little no
higher than one foot herd of penguins
ascend and it's the cutest thing I have
ever seen in my life and I don't know if
I couldn't will ever have a happier
moment in my life I also was fortunate
enough to go to I'm a penguin reserve
and Dunedin where the rare the most
endangered penguin in the world so there
by the rarest as well is the yellow-eyed
penguin in native to New Zealand they're
solitary unlike every other penguin they
don't like other penguins they only hang
about themselves and they're really in
danger mostly due to habitat distraction
so it's not a few place in the world you
can see them and this is a cool little
site that has little look boxes that you
can hide in and then they just come up
close and waddle by you so you can see
this guy's like chillin out there after
a day in the ocean there's also a site
for their self that we travel to call
curio bay where this is a beach which is
also awesome because of the Petrified
Forest fossil site on the beach but if
you wait to the right time of day the
Penguins come in on shore and I'm just
sitting there on the beach penguins come
no further for me than anyone in the
back row and they just hop up you see
them swimming hop up and you watch them
go back into the forest to their nesting
sites so that's also one of those things
that all i can say was completely
magical to see some of my favorite
creatures in the wild that close to me
and only in New Zealand
you just walk onto a beach they don't
even have Park Rangers there during the
not nesting parts of year there's just
not enough people new zealand's between
remote areas like this the nearest town
yours grocery stores probably two hours
away so it's just remote enough that you
can still get very very close to nature
in some very special ways then we sort
of did a meandering trip through the
mountains and lakes of New Zealand
Queenstown was an awesome place I did in
fact your bungee jumping I don't have a
better picture unfortunately right now
but that ledge right there you jump over
the view of queenstown couldn't go to
the home of extreme sports and not
partake in one so that was me up there
looking very accomplished and then they
also have quite a few ice bars in
Queenstown which are fun to visit
although I could have just gone outside
here and experienced the same thing
milford sound one of the most
spectacular nature preserves i think on
this planet we were there on a day that
was pouring rain pouring rain but we did
get to see thousands and thousands of
waterfalls that was sort of amazing and
then there were a few beautiful sights
as you drive into the reserve this is
called mirror lake for its very
mirror-like attributes i hope to return
one day when it's not so pouring rains i
can actually see some more but it was
very fun she go see such you know you
have huge huge crevasses because it's a
few or carved by glaciers and you sail
your boat down the middle and you get to
see huge kind of mountainous like stone
and like sons of waterfalls gushing down
below we then made our way through lake
country kind of detoured from our
original plan do the weather concerns
because this is now early winter in New
Zealand where I saw probably when I
think is the most stunning view this is
like to capo you can see what's called
the Southern Alps that mountain range
throughout the south of New Zealand and
it's a glacier fed lake so it has an
awesome blue color and all I can say is
once again it's on the most stunning
views I've ever seen in my life so
having worked out with Lord of the Rings
I've bypassed most of the nerdiest stuff
for you guys but I can't ignore that I
climbed another mountain in the name of
Lord of the Rings the second movie two
towers people of Rohan live in ed Roth
that right there is Eddie Ross they
because this is a nature preserve they
had to tear down the set completely but
the whole mountain set and the little
trails they used are still
there and you can hike up to it you kind
of drive off very very beaten path down
dirt gravel roads and went up there but
it was an also kind of a rainy day but
it was awesome to say we climbed at a
rough and I got to be right there and
what's amazing about this view is this
was like not at all CG I'd edited the
views from that scene or that movie like
this is the view you get when you're up
there you can just see all these mess no
cap mountains and beautiful planes so it
was absolutely stunning so then I
basically ended up reach we ended up
retracing the steps I had formerly taken
so I'll be brief about them but sort of
made our way all the way reluctantly
back up to Auckland or are you flying
out how to stop at hobbiton again told
you the lower ranks thing is not minor
with me similarly in Wellington when we
stopped off there's the wet a workshop
the wet a cave so that's the special
effects kind of agency and props group
that Peter Jackson had founded at the
time of lord the rings they've since
done a lot of other movies but it's
really awesome they have these full
scale models and trolls and the actual
weapons used in or the Rings dutiful to
ER they're stopped off in Rotorua where
my father had been all those years ago
they're famous for their geothermal hot
springs have an amazing museum that Ian
ruined had recommended to me that I hit
so I was very thankful for that
recommendation and then we actually did
hit Blenheim before going back to the
North Island and it was cut outs
brancott estate that tasting room
vineyard and you could see there mostly
at leaf drop stage some few straggling
yellow leaves so I got to kind of see
the vineyard through the peak and
through the end of the season again I
was reluctant but actually did go to the
HMO glowworm caves it's like probably
the number one Google tourist site thing
to see in New Zealand all I can say is
do it I was blown away I couldn't
believe I was hesitant to not go yeah
these little glow worms he basically
fast for us and they lined the roof or
ceiling of these naturally formed
limestone caves it's simply breathtaking
so we made our way back to Auckland you
can see the beautiful little Sky Tower
there which we then took an elevator up
to and there's a beautiful panoramic
view around the top and SAT there
relaxing before we were catching a
flight much later that evening but I
thought it was of note on my last day i
was looking at on that bridge right
there was the very first bridge i took
out and drove off on to go to the
Northland right after picking up my car
in New Zealand and heading off
adventure so a nice big full circle of
closure so that's sort of a brief I
could have talked for six weeks about my
six-month trip try to keep it reasonable
but I really can't think that your
committee enough for this life changing
opportunity not only did I get to
fulfill a dream I've had since I can't
even remember and see some of the most
beautiful spectacular images in nature i
can imagine exist but the career
opportunities i was afforded by being
going there and connecting with
researchers and getting an international
perspective i have been told directly by
a few the people who have hired me that
it was impressive to have such diverse
experience between California New York
and New Zealand so all I can say is
thank you so much I don't have the words
so few people have been asking me what
about doing sense after I finished up my
Master's I went on to work as a
viticultural and lab technician at
quintessa but I'm actually just about to
start my position as a viticulture form
advisor for UC cooperative extension her
Merced Mariposa in madera counties so as
I said they've been told like a few
people in that position that my diverse
have had experienced greatly contributed
to me as a candidate so I'm really
thankful I got to share those
experiences with you today thank you all
for coming out please help yourself with
some wine I'm happy to answer any
questions push your hand like
wiki when you start at the percent the
17 so right when I get back to New York
I've offered a few days so hopefully
whether it doesn't mess up my plans and
then I start I've already wait a few
workshops though and sort of meeting
i'll be associated already out there so
i'm really getting it started three gold
face thanks to question so so rumor has
it that bad but Marlboros style hey like
that hands better believe that because
it's all export market most of New
Zealand ones the vast majority or export
is it mostly made for it for creation
toulouse by the way is what CEO of
American close to native Canada I belong
two types of sweden's because it is sort
of another big buyer but also American
for sure so I don't need to break up ok
lowering occupations the room to have to
they are yeah the ones that you're
getting domestically for sure have a bit
of a different me there's still more bro
soft blanc but i think they tend to be a
little more balanced in a little less in
your face green but i think that's also
they're a little more delicate I think
they're a little a little a little more
complex ones in our birth parents and
especially domestically you get the top
tier labels but they're not exporting so
like brancott estate makes a chosen what
you can get google is placed in muldrow
for a white especially
and like that's that's incredibly new
ones not at all moto style they also are
playing around a lot with oak exposure
to cell phones actually really fun to
see in taste I love it I love it was
added a lot of forms I'd love to put out
the Napa that I think these feelings
doing it very delicately as well so
that's the other flavor profile it was a
lot more there I would say there were
subdued but I certainly could and then I
will say this i just know this from my
end like Frank coffee no that's like the
US for half-life you know Sam to make so
many cases of it so for sure that being
said it's because that's who's buying
most of New Zealand's why does the
export market so I easily could believe
it that's probably true that the steps
here I haven't seen numbers to buy
anything promise that but I would say I
would agree with that well it's
interesting because we just absolutely
fell in love with the soap in your lungs
to be tried while we were in New Zealand
but we haven't been able to find any in
the u.s. that have been quite I mean
most of my labels I can't even art
export it so for me I night I do I was
out of luck when it came that some of it
like the doctors Riesling is one of my
supply absolute strength increasing at
my explains a lot of words every year
but they don't export these pretty small
productions so that's an example if
that's just all so if you're tasting at
local prolly cuz I'm trying to keep it
local mostly export one thinks that they
don't have a tasting your that I'm
anything there bottled warehouse
gentleman cargo ship there's no medium
to in which to taste their so what
you're tasting their people who are
looking at cell there so it's a
different market fit a smaller market
let's see how much time is a she goes on
a lot of mechanism we still haven't
there's toughest interview it's sort of
very bad luck most of it that's part of
it specialized in vast majority of it is
under in you know weekend for spring you
know obviously the spring you do get a
chance leasing um dos see sheep pudding
which i think is have known it fairly if
you'd love you put in there before the
very start to turn ever reason they do
better job best jobs that they've ever
seen doubt of immunity them but it's
still hand pruning good because it's a
lot of campaigns so there's no peace
agreement mechanized back and they've
enough develop flavor to do that I ever
saw is a problem everywhere you go they
rely heavily on backpackers like
traveling poker we make some money
there's a big culture of that and there
are some ties that come down and some
other you know Indonesian populations
but it's and an ultimate like the aisle
like people from Fiji you had a lot to
do and stuff on provide once they also
come from labor but it's it's a problem
that's it authorities is mechanized some
of the smaller regions work with T greed
is that can afford the hand labor and
can find it because they're also small
but they don't know you need your to see
these guys and they can cook that like
Waikiki ml comes to mind there so it's
definitely a lot of meth addition in
muldrow all that big stuff oh yeah for
sure there's just the way you harvest it
all that narrow time frame anyway but
you usually do still see some hambrick
especially more of the small at regents
that I showed on that map like some
kinda Hawke's Bay it was a lot of
handwork these leaves are these five or
so manicure with a metric laughing at
meets them like they're making
everything's naked they could sweep it
up to five or six notes and everything's
just and I have one cluster pursued and
be so perfect and manicured there's a
lot of handwork there but obviously
there's def distal machine pro so but
very little machine can opener yeah that
I saw well I know it's a lot is
backpackers bring I kept having a joke
that I could promise
sell federer pruning then I could have
been up working in the lab because I
don't want to came career well I'm sure
being in New York and I could have
looked through compared to those
backpackers you've never picked a fish
creatures before so let's yeah we have a
lot of that I think there's open the
chemical recruiting for sure but a lot
of its still hammered this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu